okay we are live what up guys welcome to
the just pearly things youtube channel
today i have a special guest
from tiktok i have sonia maya it's
actually sonia
oh my god
oh my gosh sorry um but she runs a tic
tac account with over half a million
followers dedicated to sex facts
and the psychology behind sex right
yes that yeah that would be correct yeah
for the most part yes
is there anything else you want them to
know about your platform that you talk
about
yeah so i do sex education content
psychology facts
a little bit of single pride helping
people with water about
you know being alone um i do some silly
things to
try to make funny content too like funny
comedy skits like
technology fails that kind of thing but
yeah sex education and psychology are my
two passions that i like to post about
the most
and how did you get into that like how
did that start for you
so a little background i'm actually a
clinical psychology doctorate student
i'm in my fourth year
and i've been really passionate about
learning more about sex and
relationships and hormones ever since
i guess about like a year to a year and
a half ago i went to this seminar for
sex therapy couples therapy and i
learned all of these really interesting
things about
when you know a woman and a man for
heterosexual for example make love it
happens with pretty much everybody
but specifically with heterosexual
couples if a woman has sex with a man
she has more hormones that get released
that make her feel like she's
basically like falling in love with him
and it happens for men too but mostly
for women and like this kind of blew my
mind and it helped me kind of understand
myself better
in terms of like my relationships
mistakes i've made of relationships
like negative thoughts i've had after
sex also like
you know catching feelings for someone
that definitely did not deserve it
so i decided to make a tick tock video
about it i'd already been making tick
tock content for like a couple months
uh this is like last year in like june i
think
um i was making a lot of just like silly
content and then i posted like
psychology facts about sex part one
explaining what happens when a woman and
a man make love and then
that feeling when you fall in love with
the d so to speak and it went viral as
my first time getting over a million
views so that was pretty exciting so i
just like kept it going and i've been
posting about
sex and psychology ever since also i've
decided that i'm going to be a sex
therapist
along with a psychotherapist in my
future practice so
i have a youtube channel as well where i
post every wednesday about
everything that i've been learning about
sex relationships hormones
etc so could you talk more about the
difference
between like the hormones released
between men and women so women get more
attached
through sex yes
it's a slightly unfortunate because it
can lead to some
pretty like messed up situations so
it doesn't happen for everybody but when
a woman and a man make
love oxytocin serotonin and vasopressin
are like a three
three hormones that get released mostly
for women and it happens for men too but
um vasopressin gets blocked and i think
it's by dopamine so it's like
men have more release of dopamine which
is why men are more likely to get like
addicted to sex
dopamine is that addicting good feeling
that you get from like drugs gambling
chocolate you know um so they still get
hormones released but not to the point
that makes
them catch feelings so oxytocin is like
the biggest one and like when a woman
has an orgasm
it skyrockets so like let's say
she goes on a date with a guy she's like
oh he's attractive but he's not really
goal oriented and maybe he doesn't like
really
check off the boxes that she has in
terms of like her standards for a
relationship
but then she has sex past like many of
us do
in this current generation in world
and then all of a sudden she's like
wondering why
he texted me yet even though she didn't
really like him that much she's like
thinking about him a lot
and starts kind of like coming up with
this expectation and imagination in her
head of like what could be
no logically she she knows that this
isn't a good
fit because she had sex she starts
having these like
feelings and then of course there's the
other side of it where
um a man can often pretend
that he's looking for something that
he's not and it happens a lot the term f
boy a lot so
yeah boys [ __ ] boys they attack
they typically will say all of these
things like i miss you
like oh i can't stop thinking about you
but there's like saying it to get
in her head and then because she's
having you know kissing him having sex
and all these hormones are getting
released it's making it like
almost like she's addicted to this
person and the logical part of her plain
brain isn't in play in this situation
it's like the hormones that are kind of
like taking control
and it can be really hurtful because
then she starts wanting more
and that's not actually the reality and
you have to like separate
your expectations from reality
which could be really hard if you're
like having sex really fast
you know so um question
oxytocin that that's the chemical you
said that women release more
of during sex than men correct so
um i've heard something like the the
more men that a woman
has sex with um is it true that like
there's less oxytocin released or is it
the same
say that again you said the more that
men that she has sex
yeah because you always hear like the
like a girl's like first time she's like
attached to in a different way is there
a science behind that
that's a great question i haven't looked
at the research um
something that you're kind of reminding
me of is there are some women out there
that
are more comfortable with having like a
promiscuous lifestyle without
attached and then there's other women
that are
more so like i need to be with somebody
and i need that like romantic connection
so i think that's more so like what i'm
thinking about when you say that
and it also back to attachment like i'm
really into attachment theory so for
example
like a person who's been nourished
properly and has like
been taken care of in like a really nice
way by their caregivers or their parents
when growing up
are more likely to be securely attached
and then they'll
have like better situations with
relationships whereas somebody who
wasn't really they didn't get their
needs met by their parents
are more likely to be like i really need
somebody it's like they have this hole
that they try to fill
with a relationship and then they're
more likely to fall into these like
negative patterns of
like you know dating f boys or dating
somebody who's like
giving her like inconsistent attention
but still
putting up with it because there's this
like need to be with someone so i think
it's
more so that then i wouldn't blame it a
hundred percent
on the hormones i think there's a lot
more play
okay no i just always um
because i know guys like tend to not
like girls that have slept with more
like men and i'm just wondering if
there's like a science behind like why
that
is yeah i mean there probably
is um it's it's i think it's a little
bit unfair when i think about that too
because like we all kind of know that
there's a societal issue where
when the man has a bunch of women then
he's like a pimp
cooler if a woman is having sex and open
about it and oh she's a [ __ ] like it's
it's [ __ ] it's ridiculous
also there's so much like shaming out
there for for women like
expressing their sexuality online and uh
you know
you don't really get that as much to men
and it's a problem for sure
um in terms of like men not wanting
women that have you know i guess like
have that reputation
i i feel like it's almost like it's like
oh is she easy
you know i feel like in general like
when it's harder to get something it's
more enticing
yeah recently i've been talking a lot
about
uh whether or not we should have sex on
the first date or have sex
quickly because it's like the way that a
man
actually gets attached is more so from
like a deeper
intellectual emotional connection and
not from the sex so it's like
it's almost like having sex right away
because the vasopressin gets blocked
kind of limits the chances of him
actually like falling in love with her
because it's like it turns it into just
like oh i easily got that
um man is more likely in my opinion to
fall in love
if you make him wait you also make
yourself wait too because they're both
being pushed yeah
but then he's going to bond
intellectually and not just think like
oh that was easy and at the same time
if you have sex with a man really fast
he's going to think like
wow that was really easy like i didn't
really earn that does that mean that
like if i'm in a relationship with her
then she'd be more likely to like cheat
on me because
like you know she barely knew me and she
gave it up you know it's kind of like
perspective and i didn't used to think
that like when i first started posting
on youtube about it i was
i know a lot of people that have like
had sex quickly and like i don't have a
sworn parent who's getting married and
they had sex on the first date it
doesn't always happen but i think in
like
the grand scheme of people who are like
really striving to
improve their relationship like patterns
and like how they
connect with people the people that have
been having sex really fast i think they
should take a step back and really think
about it and be like
not only should i not do that because he
hasn't earned it
but like i need to give myself a chance
to really see if i like this person
before my whole control and then i
completely like my logic
just shuts down and yeah
um so what other
fat like sex facts have gone viral on
your account
my most viral video um well we're not
going to talk about the one that's the
most viral because i'm not even proud of
it
but uh yeah like a few weeks ago i had
this ridiculous video go viral
but uh the first one to go viral got 5.5
million
not the first one to go viral the best
one to go viral that was sex education i
guess you could say
um was a video where i talked about the
health benefits of using a vibrator
okay i pretty much talk about how it is
healthy to use a vibrator but like i
think in general everything in
moderation
so obviously like you've probably heard
about this before uh
maybe you have haven't but if you use a
vibrator very very often then you can
sometimes numb yourself out um it's okay
to use a vibrator as much as much as you
want to as long as you don't like
lose the ability to to like feel
pleasure but like
even if you do that you like numb
yourself out your clitoris right
it'll still go back to normal you just
need to take a break and start like
you know masturbating another way like
if you use it during sex only use it
sometimes
but like in general using a vibrator is
really healthy especially for people
that are single and
having sex like orgasms are healthy so
like have more orgasms
it'll improve your mood you'll be nicer
to people you'll sleep better
so many great things happen when you
like remember to take care of it it's
like
literally self-care and would be
stigmatized
and a lot of women feel weird about
vibrators because there's like this
stigma
and i think it's getting better but also
like during using it during sex is great
because like
for example if a woman is having sex
with a man or a woman or anyone
and like they like penetrative at the
same time but sometimes it's painful
let's say like he has a really big penis
or something like that
if you use a vibrator on the clitoris it
like makes it so much bearable
and so there's like certain things that
it helps with and
um regardless if you're like straight
bisexual
like homosexual if you're you know men
like vibrators sometimes it actually
makes it better
but there's a stigma with that too like
there's some men out there that'll like
feel insecure if she needs to
incorporate a toy in the bedroom which i
think is like
ridiculous but um that's like one of
those conversations you need to have
with your partner like if you're dating
a guy and he feels weird about using a
vibrator that's a conversation to be had
because like
that would honestly not that would be a
deal breaker for me if you like care
do you do you think that um like porn is
cheating for men is there like a
psychology behind that because
they feel like women have very mixed
opinions on porn
it's not just women like men too um yeah
there are certain people that i feel
like they just have these like
insecurities and it might be something
psychological they need to work on
i personally don't see porn as cheating
but
like when you think about the definition
of cheating it depends who you ask
because cheating can be so many
different things like you like
being too friendly with a co-worker um
it could be like you know
having like a friendly interaction with
the server and like someone could take
that as cheating like
so in a relationship it's really
important to like discuss the boundaries
of the relationship
and that includes porn um in general
i think you should be able to watch porn
even if you're in a relationship like
i have a little bit of a problem with
like the societal norm that
when you're with a really with somebody
in a relationship that it's like
every action you do even by yourself is
like it has to be
checked off by another person yeah um
a healthy relationship in my opinion is
like when you have that talk
but i think for the most part like it
should be okay
to please yourself with poor um
but yeah of course there's some people
that see it as cheating
i just i think that it's possible that
people that are have those insecurities
they want to talk about with their
partner and if it becomes an issue then
maybe they should talk to a sex
therapist
because there has to be like a
compromise you know
if you have to say bye to porn forever
because you found someone you're
compatible with that could be a deal
breaker for some people and
would be really uncomfortable like well
and i've i don't know um i've heard a
lot especially in marriages like a
problem that comes up
often is that men want to have sex like
more frequently than women
um so it seems like porn would be a good
way to like even that out almost if the
woman doesn't want it as much as the guy
does
i think that that might be true
statistically but
there's a lot of women too that want
more sex than their partner
like and i i see a lot of comments on my
tick tock and i don't give personal
advice but like i see a lot of people
like
relating say and having something to say
about it and
yeah i mean i think it would be good to
like be able to give your partner that
freedom
to please yeah like of course there
might be one person who's really horny
and another person who had a really long
day
and doesn't feel like having sex and
it's kind of unfair it's like
because you're with somebody you can't
get off because getting off is now like
a
you and them thing you know um yeah i
think that porn would be a good solution
for that like if she
she or he was okay with it and it should
be in my opinion but
you know of course there's going to be
some people that don't feel that way and
um i'd rather like in that situation
let's say it's a heterosexual couple
and the woman doesn't want to have sex
and the man's really horny i think she
should let him masturbate
rather than giving in and it being like
this one-sided sex where she has to like
fake an orgasm
or whatever maybe like that's not
healthy either so
um so speaking of cheating okay the most
interesting fact
i saw on your page was 39 is the danger
zone for cheating
men age 55 to 65 is the highest rate of
cheating in 48 to 45 for women
that this is super surprising do you
know why that is
so for the nine thing i had to post
about it because
this research is pretty cool it's like
when you think about
that those thoughts that we have i mean
i guess i'm not really like that there
yet but like you think about how people
have like those midlife crisis is or
like you're about to turn
30 as 29 you're about to turn 40 which
is like a big one
and you're 39 you start feeling kind of
insecure like maybe start
questioning your life decisions and
you're like am i really doing what i
want to do in my life like
are things going the way that i want
them to go if you're in a relationship
and it's possible that there might be
some like uncertainties there
you're more likely to cheat because
people use cheating a lot of the time as
like a self-esteem booster um
no it's definitely not okay like there's
generally
a reason for it like in terms of like
maybe they don't feel like they're
getting enough attention from their
partner
or their sexual their sexual
satisfaction is low
in general there might be some kind of
issues and
they're more likely to cheat at that age
because it like
just being at that age can be so like
psychologically detrimental for people
that are like going through that like oh
my god i'm about to be 30 oh my god
about to be 40. and they need
a little bit of a boost in self-esteem
and it's totally an unhealthy way to do
that
but the statistics show that that's what
they do well it's interesting because
i don't know when i think of someone who
cheats i don't think of it as an
insecurity and i know i hear that a lot
i think of it it's just they were horny
and they wanted to
so what so what like how do you know
it's an insecurity
is it like do you they survey the people
or how does that work
yeah i write a research study where um a
bunch of people were surveyed that
had cheated on their partners and they
were asked like why and there were so
many reasons why
um and and one of the like highest
reasons would like they
they felt like neglected by their
partner oh okay
it's not like it's probably not
consciously like a self-esteem booster
not be like oh i'm feeling really down
on myself let me go have sex with
someone else it's more like
like people are less likely to cheat if
they're feeling satisfied
and like seen by their partner like
you'll
like you have this open communication
with your partner that you feel like you
could do anything you feel like you feel
like masturbating private you know like
some like i don't know if i'm really
comfortable with what i'm in right now
and i also feel like if someone's
married and have
kids they they feel even more stuck
sometimes even if the health like the
relationship isn't healthy
um a lot of people are like they
sometimes they cheat
even just to stay in the marriage
because it's easier to like
go outside of their their relationship
and be unfaithful than it is to like
uproot their life
and like you know leave the children and
then there's the custody thing so like
some people just
find it easier and there's even this um
there's this like a bunch of these like
apps or this is one website
where um people actually the the point
of the dating app
is to find other people that are married
and it has
so many users it's it's i think it's
called ashley madison
yeah i've heard of it yeah posted about
it in my youtube video i think like
uh a week or two ago um but it's really
interesting because there's so
many people on there and they're
literally just husbands and wives
looking to cheat on their husbands and
wives and it's just like
it's very important what i um
i think in 2021 sorry
it's easier to cheat than it was 50
years ago as in like there's apps and
you have more access to people
but i also think it's easier to get
caught because there's so
there's like a digital trail now
yeah you might be right about that and
i'm not super
knowledgeable about that um i don't know
that like technology has made it easier
for people to cheat like you could be
cheating while laying right next to your
bed and
partner in bed and they don't even know
because that is cheating to a lot of
people when you're like flirting with
somebody
so you can technologically cheat like
just like that so easily and swipe and
all of that
but yeah it's definitely easier to get
caught as well um
yeah um so
another thing that i found interesting
on your page was um birth control
actually affects how women pick a
partner
and who they're attracted to could you
talk a little more about that
yeah so there's some birth controls that
have like an impact on your hormones and
um it's so crazy when i talk about birth
control too like it can have
an opposite effect too in a lot of ways
um
but yeah sometimes some birth controls
will make it so you
uh are like less attracted to men with
high testosterone which i think is
interesting um i i would argue that you
could probably say the opposite happens
too it's just there's a particular study
that
that showed it was also more like a
self-report thing too
based on like women with and without
birth control like at a
between group study kind of thing and uh
yeah i just thought it was interesting
so
i realized on tick tock it's really hard
to educate
people in like the short amount of time
that we have but the videos that have
gone the most
views for me are like three sex facts in
less than 15 seconds but it's like
so hard to really teach people in that
short amount of time but like
the way tic toc the reason why it's so
successful in my opinion is because
people have like shorter and shorter
attention spans so like
learn something in like 15 to 60 seconds
like they're more likely to pay
attention
than you know the people that watch my
youtube i'm like wow you must really
like love my content and support me
like you're willing to watch like a 10
minute video um but
it's kind of sad how that happens but i
think that was on like one of one of
those examples like i could say a fact
like that and it's so interesting
but i have a chance to like elaborate on
it because i'm trying to like fit all
this information
like tiny little yeah that can bubble so
i can like
get out to more people yeah no i found
the same thing on tick tock they it
really does not favor long
videos especially like now that they
have the three minute option
like my page has not done well with
those yeah it's hard it's really hard
because
to really like be engaging to the point
where people are actually going to stick
with you for 60 seconds and
the first time i went viral for
psychology facts about sex part one
it was a 60-second video so i was
surprised
um but like i've looked up a lot of
strategies on how to blow up on tick
tock and they say like 14 seconds is
like
really good and then if you go anywhere
over like 45
then it's gonna be really hard to blow
up and i'm just like i
a lot of mine i really do use the full
60 seconds it's just
i you know there is this like urge for
me
like i'm like i should try to do more 15
second videos to get out to more people
those do the best but um
so my audience is 95
men on youtube so what do you think the
biggest like misconceptions men have
about women when it comes to sex
i think one of the really big ones is
the fact that a lot of people don't know
that only one third of the female
population
can actually have an orgasm from
penetrative sex
meaning like the people that can come
without
like rubbing having stimulation to their
clitoris at the same time
so most women the majority of women get
off from clitoral external stimulation
and i think that's a really big
misconception and we're not taught about
that in school like
in sex ed we're taught about like
anatomy and
where a condom and stds are scary and be
scared about sex
like i feel like that was my experience
and most people would agree in america
at least
i think they'd be better job in other
countries but they should tell you that
too like about orgasms they should tell
you orgasms are healthy they should tell
you
you can you most women come on the
outside because
for a woman that doesn't know that and
they can't come from just like
sex and they're with somebody uh
in general whoever it is that doesn't
like care to like
find out what feels good to them they're
not going to enjoy sex they're probably
not going to even want to have it and
they're probably just going to have it
to like
for for the sake of the other person and
like fake and orgasm and all these
terrible things so yeah men should know
that
most women need their clitoris
stimulated
um they should care to ask um
men and women that have sex with with
women anyone that has sex with a woman
or anyone that has sex with anyone
should like communicate like what do you
like is this nice dude like want me to
do
or you kind of thing um and also men
should know that foreplay is really
important
like for most women there are some women
out there that are like no let's just
get straight to the action but
the majority of women will really really
need to be like
they need their oven heated up
essentially like
we won't be able to even enjoy sex
unless they're completely turned on it's
like very very
very mental it's like 90
uh in your head it's like very very
important that you are mentally turned
on because like
if you ever had to try to have sex or
have an orgasm and your like mind is
somewhere else
or if you feel uncomfortable you feel
insecure you're thinking about like
oh do i look weird like you're not gonna
be able to come so
i think everyone should keep that in
mind especially men
that it's like a two-sided thing and uh
there's nothing wrong with her having a
vibrator
what is it what does it mean to be
mentally turned on
mentally turned on means like what i
just said about how
you're when you're horny like
your mind is like
it's hard to even explain like i mean if
you've experienced you've experienced it
you're just like
i want this pleasure i want this person
to feel this pleasure
you feel like this connection and this
excitement and your hormones and
endorphins and everything is like
that really good feeling when you get
it's almost like that almost kind of
like the after workout feeling euphoric
feeling
um mentally turned on means like you're
in it a hundred percent
and you're like so horny that you're
really like immersed in the moment
you're not thinking about like
like or like you're not thinking about
that test you have
like i've i've caught myself in the
moment like in the moment sometimes of
like thinking about something i'm like
why i'm like what am i doing i'm not
even thinking about like
i'm not even present in this moment like
you know how this meditation like being
aware and being mindful and like being
there like it's almost like you're not
even there so yeah of course you're not
gonna enjoy it you're not going to
experience the pleasure if your mind
isn't in it you know what i mean
so how can guys um help girls to get
more mentally turned on
like foreplay and also if she likes it
like compliments are really good
so if you pray or compliment her like
tell her how beautiful she is
something else that is that yeah since
you said most of your viewers are men
like i've been trying so hard recently
to like let
men know on instagram on my like posts
and i need to talk about this on tech
talk more
like the way you compliment a woman
makes such a big difference like women
that don't know you that well they don't
like to be called sexy
and hot there are so many men out there
that are like oh my god you're just so
sexy and like they don't understand that
that's like not
it doesn't make you feel as good as like
if you say like gorgeous beautiful
stunning
like like those are the better ones to
use because it's like
unfortunately this this sucks that like
society's like this but like
if a guy don't know that well it's like
you're just so sexy i'm automatically
thinking like
you just want to [ __ ] me and you don't
want to get to know me
like it almost feels objectifying in a
way
um and i know they don't i don't think
they mean it honestly
i just don't know how to compliment but
like in the in the midst of like
it's a first date second date it's
casual sex it's maybe it's like actually
dating
if you're about to like have sex you're
just so beautiful like
point out like how gorgeous her eyes are
and like how stunning she is
she's going to probably like that more
and i've done a poll on instagram and
tick tock
and like it was like 90 of women agreed
like i don't like being called sexy and
hot violet unless you're already like
dating somebody yeah that's fine like if
you've been dating someone for a while
it's like yeah call me sexy or sexy too
but like
we don't know the man that well there's
a difference like i'm not i'm not there
yet
well i think guys make that mistake
often is they they come on like too
strong too fast yeah sometimes i think
guys come on to girls the way like they
would like girls to come on to them
like i think a guy would love it if a
girl just came up and was like you're so
hot and sucks
you know yeah and the whole thing thing
too like
it's ridiculous like it's non-consensual
when you send a woman a dick pic i
guarantee you
almost none of us are sitting around
like like oh my god i hope i see it
no like i don't understand what it is i
mean but i'm sure they would love for us
to be library
and then when i'm done with my doctorate
in psychology i'm to get my postmasters
in like human sexuality so that i can
be a sex like a psychotherapist like a
regular therapist but also add on
couples and sex therapy to my practice
just so i can help people more like yeah
it's like
sec there's almost like not a such thing
there's there used to be this thing
where you were just a sex therapist
that's like not a thing anymore
um and do you know about dr ruth
have you heard of her before um let me
google her to see if i've seen her
face doctor her name is dr ruth
westheimer she's the most popular sex
therapist in the world
people call her the freud of sex a
grandma
she's like 90 something years old like a
short
woman she's she's amazing she's
wonderful she's very famous she has a
documentary on hulu about called ask dr
ruth she used to have a show
called ask dr ruth the way she got
famous was back in the 70s when it was
really taboo to talk about sex
she started talking about sex on this
show called
sexually speaking that was on the radio
because like in the 70s that was like
the tick tock
you know like at the radio so she
started this uh show where people would
call in anonymously about their sexual
issues like my dick isn't working
i don't know how to please my wife i
can't orgasm and she would take these
calls on the radio and then it blew up
and went viral and then she became
famous and had a talk show but like
she was very um like courageous to do so
because back then
it was like really squeamish to talk
about sex so that's how she got famous
and she's like um she's like this
bullet in society like you know she's
like
really she's like one of my inspirations
and she's friends with my uncle
so i've actually talked to her before
and at the beginning of coven when i
first started
talking about sex and i first went viral
and tic tac i was like i talked to dr
ruth on the phone
and she was telling me she's giving me
advice she was like if you want to be a
sex therapist
just so you know like there aren't just
sex therapists anymore like you
you should be you know you're finishing
your doctor be a psychotherapist and
then
add sex therapy to your to practice and
i was like okay
that sounds good and i wanted to ask her
advice about like
my online stuff but she's not versed
with that like people post on behalf of
her on like twitter it's not even her
she has like a team
but she's like still doing all this
stuff she just came out with this
book called sex for dummies part four so
like a lot of what i've learned and i
talk about is
based on her information and she was
just on ellen a few years ago she's like
big deal i don't agree with everything
that she says like for example
she's a little bit more old-fashioned
like i believe in
like there's some people out there that
are polyamorous for example
and they are more interested in like
you know multiple love if you you know
people on here who aren't
familiar it sounds like you are from a
thing yeah um there are a lot of people
out there that aren't into monogamy
monogamy is like this like societal norm
like you have to be with one person it's
been like that
for for years generations that's what
like dr ruth is more like you need to be
with one person and have a family like i
don't really agree with that because
there's some people out there that
that don't want to be with just one
person and that's healthy for them
there's people out there
swingers or in open relationships and i
think that's fine i think that
you can also have a successful threesome
without it like ruining your
relationship but like dr ruth thinks
that
if like a man and a woman or a woman and
a woman or a man a man or in a
relationship and they like
you know how sometimes the couples will
be like let's spice things up and like
find a girl to have sex with is very
common uh she doesn't think that that's
a good idea she thinks it'll always
end in destruction i don't think that's
100 true i think if you have like
a solid foundation and a healthy
relationship you could
add a little some action in there
without ruining things so
i feel like i'm dr ruth is such an
inspiration for me and like
an idol in my sense because i want to be
like the new generational dr ruth in a
sense
with more like open-minded and like
less old-fashioned perspectives and i'm
also bisexual too so like a lot more
like
lgbtq pride focus than she
he has yeah well historically monogamy
wasn't even
the norm i mean like kings had multiple
wives like one in 200 people can trace
their
roots back to ganga's khan
yeah perspective too but what was it
like a norm in society i mean
kings can kind of just like do what they
want right but like what about
people who weren't kings like we were
they able to be like
yeah i'm gonna have like two girlfriends
with people frowned upon it because like
from my understanding they would but i
don't really know
a lot about that um from like from what
i understand like
the top percentage of men basically
would have like it was like
80 of women reproduced were only 40
of men did so it was like two girls for
every one guy basically
wow and there's some there's some
cultures that still do that yeah
one like it's like a mormon thing right
mormons do it too so
but um yeah no that's definitely true
and if you think about it culturally of
course there's some
cultures that are like it's fine but
like when focusing on like america
and like this generation it is getting
more open-minded but like
when i'm thinking about like the 60s 70s
80s like that was kind of like
frowned upon but but so were so many
other things that are totally fine like
you know
being who are being homosexual being
lesbian like
i'm really passionate about talking
about that because not too long ago it
was in the dsm
to be gay which is insanely thick that
was a thing
luckily they got they got rid of it and
now it's more like
lgbtq is getting a lot more like
prideful
still an issue and there's still stigma
but i'm like hoping it'll keep getting
better and better because
i'm just like i'm just like oh i would
have hated to live in that generation
where like being gay was frowned upon
like
it probably would have made me like
depressed yeah
no i don't i think that's crazy that it
was actually a mental disorder i did not
know that
yeah and they tried to like shock it out
of you they would use like
electric shocks to to men's brain to try
to get them
they they would literally like show men
pictures of like that would arouse them
and like shock them
so they wouldn't it would like to it
wasn't called elect i think it was like
electric aversion therapy
is terrible like yeah the the history in
psychology is like really dark and a lot
of people don't know about this stuff
and never in a lot of papers on it
and um oh i should probably mention this
too i'm doing my dissertation
on why we should talk about sex more as
a society
and i'm going to be interviewing a bunch
of other psychotherapists who've been
a psychotherapist for like at least
three years and asking them do they talk
about sex with their clients
why are why not do they talk about lgbtq
topics with their clients like let's say
you're a therapist and you have a gay
client
and are you comfortable talking about
like the struggle and the stigma that
kind of thing
so i'm going to be interviewing
psychologists and that's a research
project then about to start in this
upcoming month i just passed my
dissertation proposal so
that's really exciting i'm really glad
that i have the opportunity to do like
research on something about and i'm
i'm becoming more passionate about it
because
i don't know if you know about this but
that's educators are being like
attacked on tick tock right now
including
um about five or six months ago
i started getting violations for the
same thing i've been doing for over a
year
and just for saying the word orgasm
penis vagina so i started like changing
my terminology if you were to scroll
through my page
you'd see i used to say orgasm and those
videos are still circulating on the app
they're still being
shown people but if i god forbid say the
word orgasm
or write the word sex i will get a ban
in a second
and report me too so i started changing
my terminology i say
sex instead of sex i say um like i say
taco instead of vagina or
the jj or like burrito or crema instead
of like you know i i i'm strategic and
it's worked a little bit
to be honest with you it's not really
working that well um the moderation on
tick tock is a huge mess
so bad it's so bad they take everything
i got banned for like two weeks the
other day it was
terrible that's so stressful and then i
gave it back to you
well sort of i got my device banned so i
can't
this phone i got two phones now i'm like
a baller
um
but i literally bought this phone
because i can't go on tick-tock on my
main phone
what yeah like my device is banned
but you can go on the other one though
yeah my account's not banned just my
device
i've never this is news to me i didn't
know i've never actually been like
you know how they temporarily or
permanently ban people like i have a lot
of friends
i'm actually a group chat on instagram
with a bunch of other educators that are
struggling with the same thing
so we can vent to each other but we're
also trying to come up with like
a change id because a lot of us feel
like we're being targeted
and it's really frustrating i could like
bend about this for hours because
as you already know like there's wet ass
[ __ ] went viral and tick tock there's a
song
[ __ ] me right now and i tried mouthing
to it for like
there's these companies that like pay me
like like 25 30 or 40 dollars to use
their audio
so all i did was like mouth to a a song
that's already viral on the app with a
bunch of like
famous people doing it and i got a
violation because i did it
but it's already a sound so like why are
you sound and then the fact from eminem
about like sticking a gerbil up your
butt that went viral on tick-tock and
i'm like
how am i not allowed to say like sex
when there's these really really really
promiscuous songs that are going viral
on the app that 13 year olds are dancing
to
and i'm just like this makes no sense
but there's no one to talk to about it
when you like message the
the report help center they give me this
robotic response that just
reminds me of like the purpose of
violations like the purpose
of they say we allowed people to to
report the content in order to like
to keep a safe community and i'm like
well you're not answering my question
because on the uh on the violations like
when they when you get a violation
and you get i get the one that says like
sexual nudity content
it says we do allow content
sexual in nature for educational
artistic purposes
for his political purposes and i'm like
that's exactly what i do
and there's only been one time where
they've given my video back that was sex
educational every other time that i
appealed it they deny it with no
explanation and then there's nothing i
can do
and a lot of like a video that's already
on my account like i don't know if you
know this but like it's a strategy
if you have a video that does really
well you can repost it in like a couple
weeks and then it'll
again it's like milking the content you
could do it like three different times
safely
if i i did that with a video that
already got like 400 000 views a few
weeks ago
i reposted it the other day violation
i'm like
it's already on the app though and this
is what this is what i tell
um have you heard of the manosphere
what's that um that's like what my
channel is about
so it's like i react to men's dating
advice on my channel
and i just say if i like it or not it's
like men's self-improvement
men it's like all content like for men
but
some so the ones that i watched of yours
i scrolled through it like yesterday and
today i watched a lot of your um like
the
fear of rejection challenge that that
one
no my um youtube's very different than
my tick tock i can't post this content
on my
tick tock because it's too it gets it'll
get taken down i'm just now
you know what you're saying yeah well
okay yeah no tell me more about that
no so it's like it's interesting because
they'll use like psychological tricks to
um like try to get girls and it's
interesting like
hearing things that have like worked on
me or not worked on me before you know
what i mean are like things i've seen
guys do but just from their perspective
and they're getting this from like
watching other youtubers talk about it
like yeah getting the strategies um like
i'll give you an example like of a fact
that i
never realized um out of 100 out of them
ten
single men how many do you think are
sexually active
out of ten um
like sexually active in terms of like
having sex with
other women right yeah straight this is
for straight guys because it's
strange population or america
gosh i don't know i'm guessing america
but i'm not 100
out of 10 i would probably say
four um so 20
of men have sexual access to 80 percent
of women
so it's um so it's funny because
like like what is it out of ten then two
so twenty percent oh just two twenty oh
twenty percent out of oath okay okay
yeah so it's like um there's just a lot
of really frustrated guys because
basically all the girls are dating the
same guys that's why like you'll
see so many girls that are like men are
trash men are the worst
because they're all dating the same guys
where 80
of men like don't get anyone and once i
saw this i couldn't unsee it there's so
many guys that you just like don't even
notice
in your day-to-day life like guys
shorter than you guys that aren't like
super attractive guys whatever
um and so it's basically like dating
advice for the bottom eighty percent of
men like trying to get into the twenty
percent
but it's censored terribly like on tick
tock
basically any big content creator in the
manosphere they would never make it on
tick tock
because so i mean some of their advice
is bad like for example
they tell like fresh and fit tells girls
to have sex with 50 women
just so you don't get attached to each
one like i i wouldn't tell someone to do
that but
you know i'm not going to tell them what
what is fresh and fit
oh that's like in my opinion the the
worst
i don't want to say worse because i
can't say what dating advice is the most
effective
for men if you're just trying to get
laid if that's your goal i don't know
um but i would say their advice bothers
me the most as a girl
um because they say like for example if
you are on a date with a girl and you
bring her home
and she doesn't want to sleep with you
say okay you can go i'm going to call up
another bed
like another girl no like that that's
the type of stuff they but i'll react to
it i'll watch it i don't care
like it gets me views so i'll watch it
but
i'm like i've watched one video that was
like how to get a girl to have sex with
you and it made me like cringe
it was so yeah yeah i was like oh my god
men are actually like watching this
and like really trying this stuff yeah
okay um but no that but they always
think
it's just the man-o-sphere they're like
oh it's just because we're part of the
man of spirit
but like guys people on all different
groups get banned from tick tock tick
tock does not discriminate
that's true yeah i think
someone who talks about something like
that probably does deserve
that because in terms of like the bad
stuff that they're saying
people like that and not the people that
don't deserve it yeah
i see i don't think so because i think
if you have bad advice like
shout it from the rooftops i like i
think if you look like an idiot
i don't care you know what i mean like
go look like an idiot
and i think like most people with like
common sense can see what's true and
what's not
unfortunately i i don't think common
sense is very common so i would have to
disagree because
somebody who's so desperate to be with
somebody
they might really take that advice and
they might
like actually believe it so
i think that like the reaction videos
that are like actually teaching
this is not this is wrong those are the
ones that are good but
i i wouldn't like want more of that on
tick tock especially
how many young people on the app like
i'd rather them
see i honestly i don't think there's
anything wrong with like
a 13 14 15 year old hearing that orgasms
are healthy because that's when you
first start
learning about it you one person could
argue that sex education isn't good for
that app because of how young people are
but i'm like no i'm teaching people what
they're not being taught in school right
now so i don't agree
but like what you're saying in terms of
like from the rooftops i wouldn't want
like a
13 year old boy who's like just like oh
how can i like get a girl to like
hear someone like that and then not hear
the reaction video
and believe and share with his friends
and there's a lot of really problematic
stuff on
on tick tock too like um
no i don't i don't disagree with you
with like age restrictions
yeah you know but i think if like an 18
plus year old wants to look at bad
dating advice
i don't i don't see why they shouldn't
be able to
yeah but for kids no like it's actually
the whop song i could not believe all
the like 13 14 year old girls that i saw
doing that
yeah i mean it's it's so ridiculous to
me
that that exists on the app and then
they're shutting they're moderating
things that don't deserve it
that to me is like it makes me want to
really like spend a day focusing on like
who can i contact
and i i was thinking about maybe like
emailing people that work for that
i've heard about people doing that like
emailing people who work for the app
kind of thing i don't know i just want
to be able to get to somebody i'm like
is there a way that i can like connect
with someone from the new york times
who like write an article about it like
how do i make an impact and make a
difference because it's gotten really
ridiculous and
i have tick tock anxiety too it's like
opening the app like i'm scared because
um not only is it it messes with me
like my mental health a little bit when
i get violations and i know i don't
deserve it and that's nothing i could do
about it it makes me feel helpless
because it's like
everything was going so well and you
know it's very like it releases my
hormones to see that
more followers more views i'm helping
people people are giving me positive
feedback saying that my content has
helped them with their relationships and
their view on sex and that they need my
content and that feels great but then
i have other people who maybe don't
agree and who are like anti-sex talk who
are reporting me or whatever the case
may be
it gets me anxious and then as soon as i
get a violation
it's almost like i get put in like tick
tock jail and my videos don't do well
for like
days like see the difference i'll have
like thirty thousand forty thousand
fifty thousand sixty thousand as like my
average
and then all of a sudden it's like one
thousand two thousand one
like this is they're not no that's
enough i'll tell you what you have to do
you have to find someone that has a
couple million followers
they they get a representative from tick
tock if you get big enough like a direct
person that works there they get their
cell phone number
so i i'm not big enough i don't have
that really
yeah but i've i've met people that do
and they have like like if someone
big on tick tock wants a video taken
down they can just like
text tick tock and like get it taken
down
really yeah even if like
so it is 2 million like the golden
safety because i've noticed that
like let's say someone with millions of
followers puts like a thirst trap video
in a bikini
no problem i do that automatic ban
because my boobs are big
so i've noticed like okay so if i'm a
celebrity or if i'm like verified and i
have millions of followers i can
technically do whatever i want
and this is the same content if i'm
doing it like same example with like the
fmrn song there's there's tick tock
celebrities doing the same thing that i
did and i'm getting in trouble so like
is that the magic number two million i
don't
i don't know if it's necessarily numbers
um
like for example do you know tanks
no okay like t-i-n-x
tanks maybe i don't know how to say her
name
i don't think so okay well she's got
about a million on tick-tock and she's
verified
but this other guy that i follow called
one leg wonder he's got
two or three million and he's not
verified and i don't think i would doubt
he has a
rep at a tick tock so i i think part of
it's just like knowing someone there
and the second part is having a lot of
followers i would guess
at 10 million like you definitely have a
rep at tick-tock but i don't know what
the cut-off is
i think verification makes a big
difference in terms of like the
protection that you have
but during like i i've looked up videos
how to get verified on tick tock it's
like really
freaking hard and i have so many
violations on my account that i don't
know if they'd even
consider like i'm losing a little bit of
hope but i don't want to lose hope i
just want to figure out
like if i could sit down with somebody
or like email someone back and forth or
have them number to text i would know
i would know exactly what to do like
actually doing anything wrong or am i
just being victimized
because i mean i actually already know
i'm not doing anything wrong because if
it says in the
in the guidelines you could do
educational content about sex
then i'm clearly being targeted and not
just
many others i'm sure thousands and um
there's other people posting about it
but they're not
they're not like millions of followers
like i haven't seen anyone with millions
of followers since they're not having
that issue
but i've seen other people who are
smaller and there's this one woman
who's like a professor who's like
recruiting people
for a study about moderation on tick
tock and i like applied to it
so i hope that a change gets made
because it's very frustrating it's
and i i want to keep doing what i'm
doing if i lose my account then
that would that would really put a stall
in in like the goals that i have for
myself
yeah and for my outreach so yeah
exactly anxiety provoking we've had some
issues too like have you ever had an
issue with like videos getting taken
down in general
like violations yeah um
i've had some get taken down not not
crazy like you because my
my tic toc i don't um
just because i i can kind of remove
myself like i don't put the manosphere
content that i know would get taken down
on tick-tock
and that's not what my whole account's
about you know so
does that make sense so i i can avoid it
a little bit easier than you can where
you base your whole account
on sex facts and like sex i do post like
psychology facts too
which can do really well and sometimes
they do so i've like thought to myself
i'm like this inner conflict i'm like
should i just focus on psychology and
relationships to keep myself safe
and not do sex just to keep myself and
keep my account and not have any
s or should i just keep doing what i'm
doing because i'm passionate about it
and that would be like me giving in you
know
i'm very conflicted about that i know i
know what the safer option would be but
like
i know my my uh followers
wouldn't like that as much and i might
lose followers and
recently i've been noticing that i used
to get like a thousand to two thousand
followers every day
and like it completely stopped happening
like a month ago
i don't get followers every day and my
followers started going down but then i
heard that they were like removing bot
accounts and stuff like that
but that was right when they introduced
the opportunity to promote your content
so i'm thinking like
i'm pretty sure from like i'm pretty
sure what they're doing
is they're taking away followers because
also some of my followers told me that
they were unfollowing me but they didn't
hit on follow so
tick tock in my opinion is taking your
followers away
so that you'll pay for promotion to get
more followers
which is sneaky so there's a lot of
stuff going on that i don't know like
the truth and it's just like
well it's a little irritating now i've
been there
a lot i've been people i feel like
people who want to have conservative
relationships are getting forced
but by hedonists sex should be
careful thank you for the donation i i
just genuinely don't know what that
means
comments going on i can't see them no
i don't know i just looked at that for
the first time there were comments this
whole time
yeah yeah no i mean i've been like
reading them
some of them if i felt like it would add
to the conversation but if someone
donates i always read it
i just genuinely yeah verse by hedonist
hello everybody i didn't i was on
private chat the whole time and
um so to kind of circle back to your
the sex facts what are your favorite sex
facts that you've learned that have like
helped you in your life personally the
most
well four plays the core play for one
which i've already talked about so like
reminding people to use foreplay um
there's so many of them i'm like one
that's pretty funny is like um
that a lot of people say that when
they're wearing socks their orgasms are
better
so like old feet it doesn't work for
everybody um
another really interesting one is
orgasms like sometimes people have like
orgasms while they're working out but
it's like a different kind of
orgasm it's like a like like when you're
doing like um
like ab workouts some people have this
like really overwhelming
orgasmic feeling which i think is really
interesting
so that's pretty cool um i think of one
other ones
man there's so many sex facts that i've
learned um
my favorites
i think what they're trying to say is
the norms are getting pushed so far to
the extreme it's not reasonable
i don't even because the thing is people
choose to do in their bedroom
it's it's it literally doesn't matter
what the outside world tells you to do
so i don't know what they're talking
about and i'm a little confused
yeah um i mean communication is
is probably the most important thing is
communication
um and being able to open up about what
you what you like and what you don't
like and i think a lot of people
struggle with communicating their needs
and
i've also been learning a lot about
fetishes like my best performing video
on youtube is the psychology of fetishes
so it talks about like why put fetish is
the most common
fetish and it turns out that there's
like this thing that is it's
all about your brain so like a lot of
men have a foot fetish
and it turns out that the part of your
brain that's responsible for
your like the sensory of your genitals
is close to the same part of your brain
that responsible for your sensory of
your
feet and there's like there's like this
intertwining
thing that happens in your brain that
like
somehow associates genitals with
feet which is why there's so many men
that have a foot fetish so
there's like a neurological reason for
it which i think is really interesting
um and there's a lot of really like
strange fetishes out there so
i posted a couple videos about that that
did pretty well on youtube
um but i just got monetized and i just
realized like
the limited monetization thing that
happens um i'm sure you know about it
because
you're a youtuber but i didn't realize
that they limited monetization on like
keywords like sex
and you know orgasm and fetish and stuff
i'm like i i don't know how much i'll
actually be able to monetize my videos
at this point because like most of them
are limited monetization
because of like the topics that i choose
which is which is fine because it's more
about like getting the information out
than anything
i just like you know i'm learning as i
go
that works um do you want to tell them
where they can find you
yeah absolutely so my tick tock is sonya
underscore maya
i'm pretty much sonia maya everywhere on
on tiktok there's a little underscore
my youtube is sonia maya just like my
name you can just type it and then it'll
pop up
i also have an instagram sonya maya i
post reels on there almost daily
and yeah that's pretty much it tik tok
youtube instagram is where i post all of
my educational content
uh well thank you so much for coming on
um i appreciate it
i think this has been a really helpful
and interesting conversation
i agree yeah this is really nice like
talking about all these topics that
impact them all
yeah okay well thank you so much i think
i'm gonna end the broadcast now
yeah no problem that sounds good all
right it's nice meeting you
nice to meet you all right have a great
day